by the end of last week we had already
decided that we would be introducing new
measures for retail and for workplaces
when they reopen after christmas
on tuesday we decided that sporting
fixtures
will have to move behind closed doors
for the time being
and today
i can set out further measures we are
taking
to protect people's health
and to help businesses continue to trade
after christmas is over
we are introducing a new alert level 2
for hospitality businesses
cinemas theaters and public gatherings
measures that have now been tailored to
the new omicron variant
at alert level two measures
sorry about your pardon
all alert level two measures including
retail and workplaces and the closure of
nightclubs will come into force from 6
a.m
on boxing day
the new measures will mean
a general requirement of a two meter
social distancing in all premises open
to the public and in workplaces
subject to that test of reasonable
measures
the rule of six will apply to gatherings
in regulated premises such as
hospitality cinemas and theaters
all licensed premises will need to take
additional measures to protect customers
and staff
including table service and collecting
contact details
face coverings will be required in
hospitality settings at all times apart
from when seated
large events will not be able to go
ahead
indoors or outdoors
the maximum number of people who can
gather at an indoor event will be set at
30
and 50 people will be able to meet
outdoors
there will be an exception for team
sports where up to 50 spectators will be
able to gather
in addition
to those taking part
and they will be an exception as
previously for events involving children
for important life events such as
weddings civil partnerships funerals and
wakes the number who can attend
will be determined by the ability of the
venue
to manage social distancing and other
reasonable measures
and all guests attending
a wedding breakfast or a funeral wake
will need to take a lateral flow test
before attending
now the cabinet has thought hard about
how we deal with people mixing in each
other's homes and in private gardens
and we have decided not to make new
legal rules
to cover that sort of mixing we will
issue updated and strengthen guidance to
help people
keep safe
we're doing this
because we are in a different position
this year to the position we faced the
last time
we saw coronavirus rise in this way
we have a population that is largely
vaccinated
the booster is being rolled out rapidly
and lateral flow tests are easily
available
and nearly two years since the pandemic
began
we have all learned a great deal
about how we can best protect ourselves
and others now is the time
to redouble those efforts drawing on
everything that we have learned
omicron thrives on human contact every
contact we have is an opportunity
for us to spread or catch the virus and
the home
where we are surrounded by family is
where we are at our most vulnerable to
infection
to stay safe
in our own homes
we are advising that everybody follows
five simple measures
first of all limit the number of people
visiting your home
secondly
if you are visiting or people are
visiting you
take a lateral flow test before that
takes place
remember that meeting
outdoors is safer than indoors and if
you have to meet indoors
do everything you can to make sure that
it is well ventilated
if you are seeing family and friends
then space out those visits don't see
everybody all at once and at the same
time and finally don't forget all those
basic things that we've learned to do
together social distancing respect for
others washing our hands and so on
all of that
will be guidance strong guidance that
people in wales can draw on
but we will reinstate a specific offense
in regulations for large gatherings in
private homes
this is because omicron thrives in large
gatherings and in enclosed spaces
now of course we want these measures to
be in place for the shortest possible
time and that is why they will continue
to be kept very regularly under review